this is CCTV footage from inside the
Migrant Center when the fire is started
Behind Bars migrants have set fire to
mattresses one kicks the cell door
this side of the partition two men
dressed as guards appear to ignore the
place and make no effort to open the
doors
they disappear out of short as smoke
begins to spread through the building
causing multiple fatalities
around 70 men from Central and South
America had been inside at the time
in the wake of the fire the bodies of
the Dead were laid beside the building
families of migrants involved have spent
the time since looking for answers some
are still looking for loved ones
I entered the building yesterday with my
brother my wife and my two children of
two and four years of age at about three
or four pm
today when I came to answer my brother I
found out that the migration offices
were done last night
migrant support groups complain that
they are criminalized by the authorities
in this busy Crossing Point into the
United States
they complain of abuse and excessive
force used in rounding them up
these are General concerns that have
grown around the treatment of migrants
for months
pointed questions now Center on a
particular place and an appalling
tragedy
James Matthews Sky News in Washington